everybody welcome to another YouTube
hang out super excited to be here today
I've got a special guest a new friend
Felipe who's going to introduce himself
shortly but we're going to be talking
about how gratitude can change your life
and for those of you who are the
hardcore fans I've actually started a
new gratitude stream every morning for
10 minutes from 9am 2 9-10 a.m. we talk
about three things that were grateful
for the day I do mine and then also
encourage you guys to share your so this
this theme is really timely and super
excited to to share some wisdom about it
Felipe welcome aboard Felipe's webcam is
having some issues so we're just going
to go audio only but Philippe if you can
maybe just quickly introduce her
yourself to the audience so they know a
little bit more about what you're all
about hello guys this is felipe judy
from brazil hi even very nice to be here
with you and i'm from a small city in
brazil a frustrated English student and
then became a professor an English
professor and right now with 20 million
glasses thought for students in 181
countries through will say hey John what
about come which means you learn love it
so so let's talk about gratitude why you
know why is it so important to you I'm
and what's your kind of first question
around it ok for the evens fence I'm
going to ask five questions now and
share with our with our students from
will separate you have auto up in the
soda and you speak now around the world
even uh when you say believe I'm sure
there is a lot of bread dude in it but
before getting to the to the belief part
of my questions I'd like you to tell us
about your origin where you come from
your childhood your hobbies I know many
of those guys were listening to us now
are your fans and they know but people
from go separate I'll go on and our
audience in these countries around the
globe don't
you a lot and they get to know you right
now what's your region where you come
from your childhood all right we're
going we're going back in history uh I'm
Canadian I born and raised in Toronto
Canada moved around a lot visited a
couple you know a number of different
countries i guess in my time but born
and raised here my my mom was an
immigrant from Italy she's on for the
people watching the video you can see
them behind me that's me in the middle
of my parents beside me um she came here
as an immigrant looking for a better
future my father's been here for six
generations so he's Canadian gaining
through and through growing up I was a
normal kid I guess I found my
entrepreneurial calling I think a little
bit early I was five years old and
convinced my three-year-old little
sister to come draw pictures with me and
then sell them to our neighbors for five
cents insects and that's great a stand
where I tried to turn raisins into
grapes didn't realize that it was the
other way around and the grapes turn
into raisins I sold baseball cards and
have my own little initiatives growing
up but I didn't have an entrepreneurial
family and so in my high school yearbook
I said I wanted to be a banker I thought
it was gonna be a banker and then I
connect with two entrepreneurs
University and decided to work with them
and not pursue you know the high pain
banking jobs that I had opportunities
with to test this out and try it my
first company I sucked at the start it
was 19 years old we were failing i was
making three hundred dollars a month a
managed to turn that business around in
three years we've got acquired we had
customers in 30 countries sold the
companies like NASA Marilyn which
company was that I was a biotech
software company that we started then we
got I accident started I became an owner
of the business but my two partners
started
it and I joined I went from there to a
venture capital business raising half a
million to 15 million for companies to
grow and then mostly just I was
interested in venture capital I never
had to raise it so I wanted to be I just
wanted to know about it and then I
started this business helping out
entrepreneurs started with my website
and then more recently transitioned to
20 when was it even first you started
your website after the this more focused
in business itself then when was the
time you launched your website I was I
was 22 when i launched my website and
then when i started on YouTube I don't
know seven years ago six years ago how
old am I now I'm 36 so I guess 28 29 30
somewhere in there when i started may I
don't you don't look 36 at all I would
say well 22 so he started five years ago
0 36 I have a son uh hobbies I I like
salsa dancing a little bit of pho ho
haven't done that in the wild oh I
entrepreneurship league of legends
that's it ok ok ah even why did you
start believe why did you start this
channel on youtube because and you told
me you started your website when did you
decide going on youtube and why I did
not have a big master plan when I
started on YouTube I was getting a lot
of questions that people were emailing
me based off my website and say hey Evan
I have this business what do you think
can you help but do you have any ideas
and so I would spend time writing email
responses back and they would take me
you know three minutes to write back it
was a full detailed response and I just
I just got too many I mean it's
batter and it's flattering to get lots
of emails I was really grateful for
people caring and that you know that my
opinion meant something to them but it
got to the point where it was it took
too much time to do and I was getting a
lot of the same questions coming at me
consistently so I thought why not just
put some of these videos up on my
youtube channel so my youtube channel
started as one modeling success so
successful entrepreneurs that I looked
up to and just sharing some of their
stories because those stories helped
inspire me and there wasn't a good
collection online on YouTube of famous
entrepreneur stories and then involved
to me just answering people's questions
about business but it wasn't I didn't
have a goal to have a million
subscribers or you know it wasn't
something I was really tracking it was
really just I want to feel to give back
and contribute and test out this video
thing and save my myself some time from
being able to have to answer questions
and I thought for every person who is
writing with a question you know there's
a thousand more who didn't take the time
to write or didn't have the courage or
didn't know me and so if I put that
content up there then then other people
will be able to benefit from it as well
and really the whole thing started from
me being frustrated as an entrepreneur
and almost failing and telling my
partner Mike Witt and almost wanted to
give up and how hard it was going
through that early stage of my business
that I didn't want others to have to
suffer through it and it was hoping that
through the lessons I learned I could
share and hopefully people wouldn't have
to go through the pain that I did that
was if that was the reason behind the
website that was my real first entry
into the helping entrepreneur business I
guess and then it just evolved into a
YouTube channel I see I see and even you
you make a lot of thought ten rules for
success videos and I've watched most of
them okay and they're very nice what's
your favorite men I have
Lenny's stuff I remember steve jobs but
it's not my favorite my career is Bill
Gates Warren Buffett ah some days ago I
watched Stallone's Robert De Niro ah
Steve Jobs very nice too ah Bruce Lee
very nice and I'd like to ask you aren't
those videos from Bruce Lee real when
when he gets that I don't know that that
gun and he likes the the matches I know
it's an industry oh man it's an old like
I think it was a nokia commercial or
something so found out after that there
was a it was a doctored footage to make
it look like it okay but it's good i'm
glad you're a fan of the channel okay so
yeah so I've been watching the top tens
yeah and then you you started um you
started doing the top ten rules for
success and what is very nice from my
point of view is that through the
through these stars speeches you get the
message how do you understand they have
that message so have a clear vision or
believe or drink big or do not dream so
big like think of the next step you were
the one who who understand this message
behind their words how was the start of
it and how do you feel doing it now ah
so the start of it was I wanted
something for myself I wanted to push
myself I felt like the people around me
I love but weren't pushing me to be a
better version of me and so I wanted to
surround myself with some of the best
ideas and I and I had always had success
when I looked at famous entrepreneurs
from my first business from 19 looking
up to what people had done and being
inspired by and and I felt motivated and
moved by it and so I wanted I did it for
me
need to continue to have I felt like
these guys push me and I felt like if I
spend a little bit more time studying
Steve Jobs or Elon Musk or Bill Gates or
any these guys that you talk to me lost
is very nice too yeah right my skin it
isn't it if we spend a little bit more
time with them then some of their ideas
their values their way of thinking would
rub off onto me and I think a lot of us
have a limited limited mind sets in a
lot of different areas in seeing how
successful people think and work and do
their business I think we can learn a
lot from because we a lot of people at
least don't have those people in our
lives on a regular basis so if you look
at your family your parents or
grandparents or cousins or whatever you
know we love them but if they haven't
had the success that we want then it's
hard to it's hard to model them it's
hard to copy them it's hard to know what
to do and so that's why I started it was
a it was for me selfishly and thankfully
by sharing it you guys like it as well
and I wanted something consistent I
wanted to learn from different people
who the common thread at the start was
always entrepreneurship and now we've
expanded so its athletics its musicians
it's all over the place but it's people
have had success who reached the top of
their field and try to pull out lessons
from them so if you could sit down with
Elon Musk for 15 minutes and say give me
your best stuff that's what he would say
and so when we're making a video I never
know what's going to come out you know
sometimes they're people that I've never
heard of before 20 yeah a lot of people
have never heard of a lot of the
especially the non-north American
entrepreneurs no I've never heard of
these people and it's great for me too
to get awareness and some people
surprise me to you like Denzel
Washington had a great top kind that
didn't I didn't I saw this one I think
he said assistant system system system
till you get it yeah I don't know then
Zell I know I've seen his movies but i
don't really i didn't expect much i
didn't i didn't have any understanding
of what he was about going
in and yet a lot of really great
important points that are relevant not
just for actors but for people of all
walks of life no matter what you're
doing you can learn from that video so
when when I'm going into making a video
I don't know what I'm going to get uh
it's it's just by what we do is take you
know 20 hours of Elon Musk footage and
condense it down to the best 15 minutes
that that at least that we found moving
stuff that he said that was interesting
for us that me that made me think that
made me thinking well that's interesting
maybe I should apply it here and we
throw away the other you know 19 hours
and 45 minutes to try to give
entrepreneurs and anybody I guess now a
sense of what it takes to be successful
and hopefully a lot of the message are
the same but but you're here in
different ways the way denzel say it
might be different than Bruce Lee you
might be different than Bill Gates but a
lot of the messages focus around the
same things and so hearing it from
different people constantly because you
may be hearing the opposite from the
people in your life so here it is ISS
with people right here in it
consistently ah that's what forms the
change if you watch one video done Steve
Jobs great maybe that sparks a change
but chances are you'll watch it you'll
be inspired and then the next day you'll
be back to your regular life because
there's so much other people own media
around you that keep you where you are
keep you thinking small but if you're
watching it every day you can't help but
start to change and start to absorb and
start to accept some of the wisdom and
so to apply it and for me like again
it's for me and I would do it even if
you know what it was watching because I
need it for me for my growth and I'm
just super grateful that we talked no
gratitude here I'm super grateful that
people watch it they like it there
they're moved by it so that's that's the
that's the origin and I still love it
like I still love doing it it's still
you know I review every video before it
comes out
I'm filming at the start and end of
every video um I still love doing if I
stop loving it or if I stop feeling like
I was growing then I would move on to
something else yes nice so guys our
students who were watching this video
not what even saying is about the number
of videos of high quality videos he
publishes constantly I think every day
right even jugs at least three videos
every day at least three videos every
day so this is content you not only
practice your English but also get
inspired and get moved to action and
also to believe in your dreams to
believe yourself even moving ahead to
from this topic of top ten rules for
success videos that you made I know many
of those rules are constantly repeated I
know many of them think about the same
topics I'd like to ask you if you know
by heart what are the top 10 most
frequent rules for success we actually
make a combination of these so every
Friday i knows friday no let me see I
think it's every Saturday now it used to
be friday let me just check some sending
you the right info okay yeah saturday
saturday at 8pm what we do is we combine
all of the most common rules into one
video and then you see all the people
saying it so for example like passion
passion something's going to come up
consistently whether you're an athlete
and entrepreneur and inventor a musician
you have to have passion for your work
if you want to be successful and so the
video might be called passion and then
it shows you ten different people
talking about how important passion was
to them and so every saturday at eight
o'clock eastern New York Toronto time we
have that video that brings together the
most common ones I wanted to quickly
touch on something you've said in
passing about
practicing your English and this isn't
that I'm super grateful for when my mom
came from Italy to Canada she didn't
know English as she learned English by
watching TV shows American TV shows and
that's how she eventually learned
English right and it's the number of
people who've left comments on my
channel saying that they are learning
English by watching the videos really is
is amazing and for me it's a it's a full
circle moment it's something I'm
extremely grateful for because I think
about my mom and how that's how she
learned the language and now I'm able to
provide that to the next generation of
not even immigrants just people who want
to improve their English yeah and it's
so much easier to learn a language when
you're interested in the content for
sure for sure right if you're just
starting from a textbook it's going to
be super hard to pick up the language
where if you're listening to something
that Steve Jobs is saying like what was
that sentence I don't understand that
those four words I have to go look it up
because I need to understand what he
said it really makes you better at the
language and so that's something I'm
really I'm really proud of really
grateful for it's a it wasn't
intentional I didn't expect this to
happen but it's great to see it happen
and I just taking my mom every time we
see one of those comments coming nice
nice now even i know you have you have
your video for the top 10 rules for
success that was made by your family i
think but i'd like you to comment with
our students your if you can say your
top five it's not the pen the top five
rules for success you have and why you
have them it's funny that that's it's
one of the most requested videos as
people want to see my top 10 and my team
might it was a combination of my team
and in my family that made meet the
video and just fans Tamra weeks did a
lot of work hes a hardcore fan j reyez
did a lot of work he's part of my team
at hardcore
in my wife was involved so yeah people
been asking for it and since I didn't
want to make it they ended up doing it
for me so this it's worth watching I
remember what I said on there but in
terms of common things that I believe in
one back to the passion that's always
what I default to is you have to have
passion for your work whatever you're
doing and any not even your work like
you have that passion in life you have
to if you're in a relationship you have
that passion you know whatever you do if
you wanted to be successful to ask me
passion and so learning to trust that
passion and searching for the thing that
makes you excited makes you happy is
important to I guess in the business
context it's important that you are
providing value at the end of the day
business is about value it's not it's
not that complicated if you want to be
an entrepreneur you want to have success
you just need to provide value to your
customers the more value provide the
more money you make the more success
you'll have so you need to find a way to
combine what you're passionate about
with what can provide value to other
people some other common things that I
talk about common themes are expect to
suck at the start yeah so we don't
matter what you're doing at the start
you will suck and you will fail and
that's fine and that's normal when you
first start learning English you you're
terrible you know when you first start
trying to play soccer you are terrible
you know or football I guess Brazil then
we actually have a rivalry I'm half
Italian and you know world enough
sometimes around
Brazil's I wait for their ordinary
brother because they're you you guys
you're more than fine but we want four
times I'm not saying you need to expect
to set but just telling you to be
prepared all the expected suck at the
start what's important like I think
people just give up too soon people give
up too early um you know you when you
get on this on on the ski hill and you
go down the hill or a snowboarding you
know you're going to fall a thousand
times it's just it's part of it and
people expect to get immediate results
and its really the sustained effort that
keeps you going and the only reason
we're going to do that is because you're
passionate about it like the only reason
why you will stick with doing something
that you suck at is because you love it
and you want to get better at it ok so
those are some important ones what else
we're talking about guys well who's
watching live come on people watching
live what do I usually talk about we're
doing this a live stream you have people
watching right give it give it a shadow
to them let's go guys give me something
what do I talk about um while they're
thinking about it even lets you we can I
can share with our students the other
two rules but before finishing because
we're getting to to our n here is why
your one word is believed and what
message can you lead to our students who
want to speak English yes ok so I
believe everybody has one word that
defines them and mine is believed for me
believe breaks down into passion having
passion for what you're doing self
confidence and in conviction to follow
through to keep going commitment that's
that's how believe breaks down for me
and I think we all have something that
we stand for and you need to figure it
out that's what that's what the book is
all about but you need to figure it out
so that you can start to live a life on
purpose and not just be reacting
to the world around you where a lot of
people don't design a life and a
business with that degree of purpose
they may know what they're doing like in
terms of what product or service they
want to sell but not the types of people
that they want to be around the impact
that they want to have and so figuring
out what you stand for should be at the
start somebody was saying is they know a
loyal fan was saying you should add
believe in one of your 10 rules and it's
true it is but for me believe is above
everything else like all of that stuff
all the rules make up believe for me
belief sits on top of everything and in
terms of what was the question a lesson
about English for your students you know
why your one word is leaving what
message can you leave to our students
who want to speak English who want to
look more learning English so uh
practice like anything else you need to
practice having a strong why is super
important why do you want to learn
English why is this important to you it
was just to get a job or just because
you know your family says you should
that's not a really strong motivator you
need to have something that you really
feel excited about and then the fastest
way to pick up anything is is immersion
so the more time you can spend doing it
the better off you're going to be I mean
we're fortunate here i'm in canada i'm
in toronto it's one of the most diverse
cities in the world everybody's an
immigrant almost here so there's
languages you know from all over the
place so we're used to communicating
with people who their english is not
perfect every almost everybody's english
as a second language but like coming to
canada or traveling and spending
spending three months or six months in
an english-speaking country will force
you to get better if you can't afford
that then watching videos or reading
books but again the content has to be
interesting and I remember an example
thinking about Tim Ferriss who wrote the
4-hour workweek and he was trying to
learn Japanese it was have a really hard
time trying to memorize all the symbols
and figure out Japanese and what he did
it was he was really
in learning one of the martial arts from
Japan and so we picked up a book in
Japanese I built the martial arts of
Japan and then that forced him to learn
those words but he would do it because
it was interested in the subject matter
so just like we talked about Steve Jobs
if you love entrepreneurship you can
watch the videos and if somebody says
something that you don't understand
you're forced to try to figure it out
because I really want to know what Bill
Gates just said there I'm so frustrated
that I don't understand that word you're
going to go and try to figure it out or
if it was just some boring speech you're
not going to care you're not going to
put in the effort and so making sure
that you are consuming content whether
it's video or audio or written that you
feel really connected to you that you
really really really want to learn
because that desire and passion will get
through will get you through the
uncomfortableness of the work that has
to get done so you have the
comprehension all right all right even
thank you guys we're coming to an end
here but before ending unlike you guys
to see that little book that is there
your one word our students I'm just
ordering my book as soon as I finish
this call I'm going to order my book and
i highly recommend you to order your one
word book to my one word is gratitude
even one word is believed we would like
to know what is your one word youth
trainer reading your train your writing
abilities and I'm sure that we'll go ad
lot of value to your life even thank you
very much bro before finishing I'd like
you to say see you next class to all our
students alright guys thank you so much
for joining us and we'll see you next
class all right continue to believing
whatever your one word is see you next
class love it thanks felipe
you